contrôles renforcés sur les routes de
l'yonne le mois dernier le nombre
d'accidents corporels a fait un bond
spectaculaire 41 accidents et 57 blessés
presque deux fois plus qu'il ya un an le
mois de juillet a été très très très
chaud on peut penser que ça perturbe
l'attention des conducteurs et pour
finir le dernier élément que je donne à
souligner c'est que la plupart des
accidents corporels qui ont été
constatés dans le département sont des
fautes de comportement direct du
conducteur
malgré l'abaissement de la vitesse à 80
km/heure sur une grande partie du réseau
secondaire
en juillet cinq personnes ont perdu la
vie sur les routes de l'yonne
soit autant que l'an dernier concernant
les causes
le non respect des règles de circulation
et les pertes de contrôle représente à
elle seule près de la moitié des
accidents mortels
viennent ensuite la conduite sous
l'empiré de l'alcool et enfin la vitesse
depuis janvier dix neuf personnes ont
trouvé la mort sur les routes de l'yonne
un département où les accidents sont
plus graves que dans le reste de la
france
face à ce très mauvais bilan la
préfecture a décidé de maintenir les
opérations de contrôles de vitesse et
d'alcoolémie
tout au long de l'été